the ministry of time or mot is a secret
organization in Spain that works for the
welfare of humanity their job is simple
to travel back in time and erase small
anomalies that are going to alter the
future in a bad way at the start one of
mot's Agents Irene is seen in 1918
Barcelona assisting a woman in
childbirth after a lot of struggle a
baby is delivered and everyone in the
room becomes happy Irene also Smiles but
before she can join in the celebrations
she becomes dizzy and Falls unconscious
it turns out that she has contracted the
deadly Spanish Flu which was prevalent
during that time in fact the pandemic
killed around 50 million people as it
was highly contagious and deadly back in
the present world at the mot secret base
Chief Dr Vargas is discussing the
situation with newly appointed head of
operations Susanna Vargas believes that
bringing Irene back to the present is a
big risk as many people could be
infected or a new pandemic can occur
however Susanna argues otherwise she
believes that with proper Health
protocols and measures Irene can be
rehabilitated and cured she also asserts
that none of their agents should ever be
left back in time reluctantly Vargas
complies and makes the necessary
arrangements for Irene's arrival then
she is brought back from 1918 Barcelona
the situation is very Grim as Irene is
suffering from high fever and she
doesn't even have the energy to speak
the medical personnel take the virus
very seriously and wear extremely
protective suits to avoid getting
exposed furthermore no one is allowed in
the medical room apart from Vargas and a
few other medical personnel 24 hours
pass by but Irene's condition does not
improve no matter what medication she is
given the virus keeps deteriorating her
body meanwhile a nurse checks on Irene
and leaves the medical room when his
shift ends he then disposes of all his
protective gear in a separate room and
heads to the canteen unfortunately
despite all his precautions the nurse
catches the virus and he unknowingly
spreads it to a few people after a few
hours the infected begin coughing and
Vargas quick understands that his worst
fears have come true he confronts the
head of operations Susanna for her
immature decision but surprisingly the
latter still defends herself she claims
that it's the doctor's fault who didn't
use proper equipment to combat the
situation Vargas has had enough so being
the bigger man he simply leaves her bee
in the next scene a strict quarantine is
initiated inside the base meaning that
no one can exit the premises moreover
the agents that are on duty in the past
are ordered to remain there until
everything becomes normal Vargas then
summons all the employees inside the
base and explains the situation to them
after a while Susanna takes over and
reassures everyone that there is nothing
to worry about however at the same time
one of mot's top agents Velasquez Falls
unconscious this indicates that the
virus has already reached its next stage
immediately all the infected patients
are brought inside the isolation room
while the others are restricted to their
own offices Vargas checks on Irene and
notices that her fever is still high but
now she has started speaking a little
shortly after Vargas checks on the nurse
that accidentally spread the virus and
draws a sample of his blood he then puts
the sample in his pocket and leaves the
room on the way out he accidentally
spills the sample and some agents
including his colleague Juan notice it
however he lies that it is ink and
departs these guys are about as
competent as the government in real life
meanwhile searching for answers some
senior members of the ministry contact a
popular physician through Skype he
reveals that in the year 1918 a German
pharmaceutical company called showbole
tried to create a vaccine by extracting
samples from dead people however it
didn't work and the company simply
disappeared 24 more hours passed by but
there is still no respite for the
patients the nurse who inadvertently
spread the flu has since passed away
while Irene and Velasquez are in
critical condition as Vargas wields the
deceased nurse to the examination room
all the mot employees look on in horror
they are certain that they will be next
that night Vargas is again on the move
this time with a big suitcase in his
hand but his colleague Juan catch him in
the ACT Vargas explains that he has to
urgently go out so that he can get some
medication for the patients Juan knows
that something is up but still he lets
the doctor go however the very next
minute he approaches the seniors and
informs them that the doctor has
breached the quarantine area he also
suspects that Vargas is up to something
as the previous day he was lying about
getting ink on his shirt it turns out
that inside the mot base no one uses red
ink after a while as Juan is discussing
with his girlfriend Shauna they notice
an employee Wheeling away some antiviral
medicine they are manufactured by none
other than the German pharmaceutical
company shobo it turns out that the
company is still functioning to this day
with this it finally Dawns on the couple
that Vargas is actually selling blood
samples of the Spanish flu patients Juan
and Shauna then immediately relay the
information to their senior leaving him
stunned in the next scene the senior
confronts Vargas for his treachery and
threatens to expose him to Susanna
however instead of being apologetic
Vargas asserts that he is doing the
right thing he claims that if if they
keep on delaying for a vaccine to be
made inside the mot a lot of people will
succumb to the virus so the best thing
to do is hand out samples to showball
who already have years of research under
their belt in return they are providing
tons of medical supplies for free Vargas
reveals that he is also getting paid
handsomely hearing all this the senior
is somewhat convinced but he still
believes that shovel may use the virus
samples for their economic benefit
perhaps they will create a vaccine and
then release the virus in public which
will cause a bigger pandemic and
endanger the lives of millions of people
Vargas replies that it is possible and
hence they decide to stop the samples
from reaching the shovel headquarters in
Munich for the mission Juan and Shauna
are dispatched they exit the mot base
and wriggle their way inside a nearby
building where Vargas apparently
conducted his secret meetings after this
they slowly approached the medical room
on the way they are forced to fight and
take down some guards at last Juan and
Shauna reached the medical room and find
the virus samples surprisingly they also
find some vaccines that were already
manufactured by showbole the following
day inside the mot medical room Vargas
injects the vaccine to all the patients
and in a matter of days they start
feeling better Velasquez is over the
moon to get a second chance at life
while Irene is happy that she can
finally work now in this way a danger is
nearly averted and after 38 days of
strict measures the quarantine is
finally lifted the agents who were
trapped in the past also returned to
their present time that episode was
about as scientifically accurate as a
speech from Donald Trump a few days
later the top agents of the group are
having a meeting about an urgent matter
at first Chief Fernando talks about the
University of Spain and its importance
to the country then Fernando points out
that in the year 1924 a drama play
titled Don Juan tenorio was made which
included several up-and-coming prominent
Stars the cover of the drama was made by
iconic artists Salvador Dali however in
the painting there is a surprising
element a modern tablet this is a
blatant breach of the laws of MOT and it
appears as if one of their agents is
messing around hence Chief Fernando
wants to send a team to investigate the
matter a reliable agent named Julian
will be leading the team in the past
while Irene will be handling everything
in the present that night everyone suits
up in their 1920s attire and heads to
mot's time machine the next second they
are teleported to the year 1924 right in
front of the student residency of the
University of Madrid when they enter
they find the practice of the play going
on the director is very displeased with
how the actors are performing so he's
berating them aggressively Julian and
the team gets seated in the last row and
witness everything just then the
director who still isn't done with his
rant gets exhausted and passes out a
practicing nurse rushes to the scene but
Julian who is the medic himself tells
her to step aside immediately the
director is transported to a room and
Julian finds out that he has diabetes
this is because in the modern world a
person with diabetes is easily
identifiable however the nurse who is
studying the curriculum of the 20s is
left in utter disbelief she doesn't
understand how Julian was able to to
find the problem in just a matter of
minutes over the course of the next few
days the group continues investigating
the matter but no leads are found
however they do manage to strike up a
good relationship with the students in
particular Julian forms a good bond with
the female nurse but one day the agents
find something very shocking it is a
modern picture of Julian with his wife
it gets even weirder there is a stamp of
MOT behind the picture this means that
whoever is behind the tablet incident
wants the group to stop messing around
that night they returned back to the
present and show the picture to Chief
Fernando the latter is shocked that
someone is going behind their backs and
using their time machine he believes
that someone very close to them is the
culprit however Irene thinks otherwise
she asserts that it is an ex-agent named
Lola who is fired for being erratic as
the discussion goes on Chief Fernando
gets some news it turns out that the
legendary painter Dali's earliest
paintings were sold just a few days ago
this is virtually impossible because
according to history all his early work
was destroyed in a fire but Julian
believes that it makes their case even
more believable whosoever is messing
with them is using the time machine to
go back in time by Dolly's paintings and
then sell them in the modern world in
the next scene the group returns to the
past and Julian immediately gets to work
he approaches Dolly and introduces
himself as a painter Julian then asks
Dolly about the person who buys all his
paintings but the latter doesn't want to
reveal this to a competitor so Julian
goes for Plan B he asks his team members
to tail dolly that evening when he heads
out to sell his paintings unfortunately
the plan doesn't work as the buyer spots
the spies and doesn't arrive at the
scene at all as Irene had suspected it
is the ex-agent Lola the following day
while the practice for the drama is
going on Julian receives another
photograph surprisingly as soon as he
sees it he becomes upset and leaves the
room the photo is revealed to be of his
wife who died in a car accident Julian
has regular nightmares about the
incident and this proves that whoever is
screwing with mot knows Julian pretty
well that evening as the group is
planning their next move one of the
agents gets a text from Lola she wants
to meet for a private conversation at
the church wasting no time the agent
reaches the location and finds Lola
there finally Lola reveals that she is
selling Dolly's paintings in the present
because they are worth a fortune
obviously she also admits that she
mistakenly left her tablet in his room
which was the root of the whole incident
saying this she prepares to leave but at
the same time Julian arrives and arrests
her Lola is disgusted that she was
betrayed but she cannot complain much
for all the problems that she has caused
later the group returns to the present
and chief Fernando congratulates them on
capturing the Rogue X agent they then
discuss what to do with her and Julian
suggests locking her up for the rest of
her life the next day the group returns
to 1924 for one last time so that they
can bid a proper farewell to their newly
made France they lie that they are
getting transferred to a new University
in a different country this is an
important part of time travel because if
someone disappears without a trace
people will start asking questions and
to chain of reactions may be initiated
yeah but nothing else that they've done
will cause any problems in the final
scene Julian uses the time machine to do
something illegal for years he has been
haunted by the death of his wife so he
wants to alter the timeline and save her
on that fateful day she was struck by a
car while jogging so Julian decides to
drive his own car and get in the way
between them the plan works and she
appears to be safe however due to the
Collision another car which was driving
at high speed swerves from its path and
Strikes Julian's wife she dies on the
spot and along with her the person
inside the previous car also dies this
proves that one simply cannot change the
timeline the show ends as Julian watches
his lifeless wife being Carried Away by
his former self a little Darkness for
you for the holiday season subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching